ce que certains considèrent comme une
avancée médicale
la pilule contraceptive ou rome vient
tout juste de passer avec succès les
premiers tests d'une étude 28 minutes
d'arte et nous en dit plus et bien
évidemment on en parlera avec nos
chroniqueurs ça fait 30 ans que l'om est
ce travail sur la contraception
hormonale pour hommes dans un relatif
désintérêt
1 les gens ne s'y intéressent pas malgré
les progrès scientifiques parce que elle
est prête à cette pilule mais alors
pourquoi elle semble si dur à avaler et
bien les réponses sont davantage société
mais que médicales la première c'est
bien sûr les hommes ont peur que cette
pilule nuisent à leur virilité
le second c'est que les laboratoires
pharmaceutiques se bousculent pas au
portillon pour développer cette pilule
peut-être par manque de business il ne
provoque pas les autorisations de mise
sur le marché
non ils préfèrent s'intéresser au viagra
par exemple qui lui trouve bien son
public et qui rapportent plusieurs
milliards de dollars par an bref vous
l'avez compris même si la pilule avance
d'un point de vue scientifique
elle n'est pas prête de sortir du tiroir
alors parce que je sens que les garçons
sont un peu inquiet mais les quelques
informations
il est tout de même 61 des français qui
se disent intéressés 61% des français
qui se disent intéressés par cette
pilule il n'y aurait pas d'effets
secondaires
en tout cas pas grave juste quelques cas
de fatigue d'acné donc voilà avant deux
trois boutons l'un des maux de tête et
des légers troubles de l'érection
voilà pris pendant mille ans assez bon
et ça sera pas sur le marché avant
disons qu est ce que vous en pensez
on va commencer par damien alors moi je
suis plutôt favorable à la multiplicité
des moyens de contraception et je suis
aussi favorable à ce que effectivement
il ya un traitement chimique pour les
hommes après tout pourquoi pas comme ça
la fécondité ne repose pas uniquement
sur les épaules de la femme vous les
trouverez est-ce que je prendrais non
pas du tout parce que je pense déjà que
il
je ne sais pas si cette pilule
contraceptive sang a remboursé par la
sécurité sociale
la pilule pour les femmes et je n'ai pas
envie que le sexy et coûte un bras déjà
et après il ya eu lieu comme vous l'avez
dit des réfections des des effets
indésirables qui ont déjà été noté donc
voilà face qui vacances pardon mais les
effets indésirables et femmes et nous
avons aussi oui c'est vrai mais il
existe des moyens de contraception qui
sont quand même moins invasif que je
prendrai donc voilà par exemple
bah je sais pas moi par exemple
l'ablation des parties génitales non je
plaisante c'est alors mais par exemple
le préservatif ce genre de choses il
existe plein d'autres moyens de
contraception qui effectivement ne sont
peut-être pas mauvais pour la santé donc
autant se tourner vers ce genre de
choses bon d'accord caroline je suis
persuadé écoutez moi bien que cette
histoire de contraception masculine à ce
taux est un vaste mensonge à grande
échelle comment ça j'ai une théorie on
l'avait aujourd'hui la médecine fait des
progrès extraordinaires avait déjà une
théorie et vous avez appelé le mot merci
n'a cure évidemment la bête et la paix
dans les mains d'un jury précieux
j'étais que convaincre quoi je vous dise
avons fait des progrès exceptionnels en
médecine on est d'accord on soigne des
cancers on soigne quasiment aujourd'hui
le sida et on est avancée incroyable
on voudrait nous faire croire qu'en
trente ans on n'a pas trouvé une pilule
contraceptive pour hommes c'est pas un
problème c'est qu'on ne peut pas donner
à l'homme la responsabilité de prendre
cette pilule qu'il ne prendra pas qu'il
oubliera et will harries damien boudet
les gros sont des gamins incapable de se
redresser mais ce qu'elle est sexy et
l'industrie nous fait croire que c'est
parce qu'on n'a pas trouvé le remède
médical alors qu'en fait c'est parce
qu'ils ne veulent pas donner à l'homme à
cette responsabilité et que du coup ils
reculent systématiquement le problème en
diamant on va dire que c'est pas de la
faute des hommes on va dire qu'on n'a
pas trouvé le le le les effets
secondaires vous avez des crises et les
effets secondaires qui existe déjà pour
la faire lapider récession c'est vrai
qu'il ya une défiance vis-à-vis de la
pilule notamment lieu avec les hormones
en revanche lorsqu'une femme prend une
contraception si elle a décidé ne pas
avoir d'enfant avec son compagnon
libre à elle si finalement il ya une
erreur un oubli elle tombe enceinte
c'est un fait en revanche si l'homme
prend la pilule et que lui oubli et
finalement c'est la femme qui va subir
la grossesse je pense que c'est un
impact plutôt négatif et que je pense
que la femme doit disposer de son propre
corps car finalement si l'homme oublie
intéressant car il faut être oui ça
m'arrange aussi ça fait bizarre c'est
peut-être très réac mais c'est vrai que
j'aurais du mal à prendre une pilule
contre les jours ça veut dire quoi cc
c'est non mais c'est très long il ya
deux poids deux mesures et wynants
d'accord très bien dites nous ce que
vous en pensez avec le hashtag sécurité
dans les pilules contraceptives forum
vous êtes pour ou vous êtes contre et
nous avez dit que vous étiez pas 66
en tout cas et non pour 34%